One of the multiple definitions
of trees that we saw
is that it's a minimum edge
simple graph that connects up
a bunch of vertices.
And that leads to the idea
of finding a spanning tree
within a simple graph that
maintains the same connections.
So let's begin with a
precise technical definition.
A spanning subgraph
of a graph, G,
is simply a subgraph that
has all the vertices of G.
So, again, a subgraph
of a graph means
it's got a subset
of the vertices,
and a subset of the edges.
Spanning subgraph is that
has all of the vertices,
but a subset of the edges.
And the definition
of a spanning tree
is a spanning subgraph
that is a tree.
Now, not all graphs are going
to have a spanning tree,
because the tree
has to be connected.
If the original graph
is not connected,
there's no way you can
find a spanning tree using
only the edges that
are there already.
But it's going to turn out
that if the graph is connected,
it's guaranteed to
have a spanning tree.
Let's look at an example.
Here's a simple graph.
And what I want, then, is a
spanning tree, a selection
of edges, that connect up all
the vertices such that we're
only using edges in the original
graph, and they form a tree.
There it is.
So if you check on these magenta
edges that I've highlighted,
they define a tree.
I haven't used three of the
edges in the original graph.
Now this particular
choice of spanning tree
is kind of arbitrary.
In general, there's
lots of spanning trees.
Here's another one, this
time with green edges.
Again, I'm using only edges
from the original graph--
I've left out three
different ones,
and used a different set
of edges to form the tree.
But there it is.
It's got no cycles,
and it spans the graph
because every vertex in
the graph is part of it.
And of course, it's
connected since it's a tree.
There's actually some
lovely combinatorial theory,
which enables you to calculate
the number of spanning trees
in a simple graph without
too much difficulty,
just given its adjacency matrix.
But we're not going to
go into that for now.
First remark is that
every connected graph
is going to have
a spanning tree,
and the reason is, you just
pick a minimal edge tree--
a minimal edge connected
spanning subgraph, rather.
So G, itself, if
it's connected, is
by definition, a
spanning graph of itself,
because it's got all
its own vertices.
That means by the
well-ordering principle,
there's going to be a
connected spanning subgraph
with a minimum number of edges.
And that one, given that it
has a minimum number of edges,
it's guaranteed to
be a spanning tree.
Now the problem gets
more interesting
when it has a little
more structure--
instead of just trying to
find a spanning tree that
has a minimum number
of edges, it's
quite typical in applications
that the edges have weights,
and we want to find a
minimum weight spanning tree.
So here's an example
where we have
a simple graph with a bunch of
edges, and a bunch of vertices.
And the edges all are assigned,
in this case, an integer
weight.
Now the motivation for
this kind of graph,
as you could think of,
these weights on the graph
as indicating the cost of
transporting some quantity
commodity from this
vertex to that vertex,
directly by a road.
Or the time it takes to transmit
a signal over this channel.
Lots of ways that
simple graphs are
used to model issues
of communication
among various locations.
And it's quite typical that
the channels and connections
between them have
different costs.
And it's a natural
question to say, OK,
what's the minimum cost overall
tree structure that will enable
me to have everything
connected to everything
else in the same way,
but that I can tolerate
some of my edges going down?
And I still would like to have
the cheapest kind of tree that
spans them all.
Well, there's a
fairly simple way
to construct such a minimum
weight spanning tree,
and that's what we're
going to talk about now.
How do you find it?
Well, the idea is to
build it using grey edges.
So what that means is that
starting off with the vertices,
we're going to start
building a tree.
And at any point,
we will have a bunch
of edges that are going to be
part of our spanning tree--
that means that the edges don't
have any cycles among them,
they're a so-called forest,
but they're not yet connected.
And at each stage
in this procedure,
we're going to look at
the connected components
of the graph that we
have at this moment,
and color them black or white.
And then look at the gray edges.
So a grey edge is defined to be
an edge where one end point is
black, and the other
end point is white.
And what I'm going to do, at
any stage in the procedure
as I'm growing my minimum
weight spanning tree,
is I'm going to look
at all the gray edges
and pick a minimum
weight gray edge.
Well, let's do an example
to get this clear.
So to begin with, I
don't have any edges.
All I have are the
isolated vertices.
So it means that I have
six connected components,
each of which is a single
vertex with no edges.
That says that I'm allowed
to color them black and white
in any way I choose,
and I will do that.
The only constraint
on the coloring
is there has to be at least
one black component, and one
white component.
So there's an
arbitrary coloring--
I've colored two of the vertices
white, and the other four
black.
Now, in this
particular coloring--
I could've chosen any one,
but I chose this one--
where are the gray edges?
Well, I've highlighted
them by thickening them.
So this is a gray edge,
because it's black and white.
This is a gray edge because
it's black and white--
black and white,
black and white.
This is not a gray edge,
because it's white and white.
because it's black and black.
So that's a simple enough idea.
Now what I'm supposed to
do is among my gray edges,
pick the one with
the minimum weight.
Well, if you look at the
weights of the gray edges,
I got a four, a four, a
nine, a seven, and a two.
The two is the minimum
weight gray edge.
I'm going to choose that
to start building my tree.
So at this moment, once I've
committed to that magenta
edge, what I now have is a
graph with five components--
namely the component defined by
this edge, with two vertices.
And the other four
isolated vertices,
which still don't have
any edges connecting them
in the structure
of magenta edges
that I'm building to be
my minimum spanning tree.
So according to the rules now,
with these five components,
I can recolor them.
And as long as I
recolor them in a way
that this component
gets the same color--
there's a recoloring.
I've made both of those vertices
in this component black,
and the other four vertices--
which are isolated components--
I can color arbitrarily.
So here's my new coloring.
Now, again, once I
have this coloring,
I can proceed to
identify the gray edges.
There they are.
And this time there are
only two gray edges,
because I chose to have
only one white vertex.
There's a gray edge and
there's a gray edge.
And of course, the minimum
weight among the two gray edges
is three.
So that's going to be my next
edge in my minimum weight
spanning tree that I'm growing.
What's next?
Well now, I have
four components left.
Here's one component
defined by that edge, here's
another connected component
defined by that edge.
And these two vertices
are isolated, still,
so they're components
all by themselves.
And the rule is,
recolor in such a way
that both of these
vertices in that component
have the same color.
All the vertices
in this component
have the same color--
I could switch them
from black to white,
in fact I will--
and those can be
colored arbitrarily.
Let's do that.
There's a recoloring.
Now this component is all white,
that component is all white.
These two separate components
happen both to be black.
I could have colored one of them
white, and one of them black.
I need to have one black, given
the other commitment to colors.
So now, again, we could
find a minimum weight edge,
a grey edge I guess it would be.
There are two ties for
minimum, both of those ones.
And I proceed in this
way, and I wind up
with this minimum
weight spanning tree.
That's the procedure.
Now I haven't discussed
why it works yet,
and that is explained
in the notes.
But we're going to
hold off on that
and just examine
applying this algorithm.
So there are a
bunch of ways, now,
to grow a minimum
weight spanning tree.
One way is to start
at any vertex,
and then keep building
around that vertex.
So you start with that
vertex and color it black,
and everything else white.
That means that all the
gray edges are going
to be connected to that vertex.
So pick a minimum weight.
Now you have a component
with two vertices.
Color it black and everything
else white, and in that way,
you keep working
on one component
that you're going
to grow by always
coloring it one
color, and everything
else the other color.
This is a method known
as Prim's algorithm
for growing a minimum
weight spanning tree.
Another one is to
globally, among all
the different
connected components,
find a minimum weight
edge among them.
So what that means is that
you find the minimum weight
edge among all the
connected components,
and then having identified where
that minimum weight edge is,
you can color one of
its components black,
and the other one
white, and that
will have to conform
to our procedure
for picking a minimum weight
edge between different colored
components.
That's Kruskal's algorithm.
And finally, you can grow
the trees in parallel.
You can just start
choosing the minimum weight
edge around each
connected component,
because you can always
take a connected component,
color it one color, and
color all the other edges
another color.
And so all of the edges
touching a given component
will be gray in that color, and
you can choose the minimum one
and grow that component.
And if they're not too
close to each other-- so
that your choice of
edges doesn't conflict--
you can grow these
trees in parallel.
So I call that, jokingly,
Myer's procedure.
And that is the application
of this coloring approach
to finding minimum
weight spanning trees.